police video of another violent incident
who has also released in America tonight
it shows the attack on the husband of
one of the most powerful politicians in
the country the former house Speaker
Nancy Pelosi a warning that Martha
kellner's report includes pictures in
the moments before and after the assault
on Paul Pelosi
this is the moment police show up to
check on the home of Nancy Pelosi and
witness a brutal attack on her husband
Paul
officers knock on the door 82-year-old
Pelosi answers with suspect David de
Pape both appear to have one hand on a
hammer but in a split second the Papas
wrestled it away and a blow Rings down
foreign
Nancy Pelosi have been married for 59
years she is one of the most
recognizable figures in U.S politics and
at the time of the attack was house
Speaker depak told police he'd been
looking for Nancy whom he called a liar
I'm here for the fight
if you stop me
you will take the punishment is dead
the attack raised questions about the
security of politicians surveillance
footage shows de Papa appearing to
stroll around the perimeter of the
Pelosi home before breaking in capital
police charged with protecting the
couple were just meters away
Paul Pelosi had part of his school
removed and spent a week in intensive
care both the prosecution and defense
fought against the release of this
footage
I have not heard the 911 car I had not
heard the confession I had not seen the
break-in and I have absolutely no
intention of seeing these deadly assault
on my husband's life
42 year old DE Pap has pleaded not
guilty to attempted murder and a string
of other charges Martha Kellner Sky News